one of the problems in life is sort of  sorting out what is realistic what is  real what is factual  uh what is put in context and social  media isn't designed to do that social  media is designed to let everybody talk  to everybody all the time and to me that  means you have to have the old values we  don't have to teach our kids to code as  much as we have to teach them to read to  write to do arithmetic to understand how  that numbers are just another language  and how to speak that language that  you're going to have to work  collaboratively and collectively and  you're not going to turn this all over  to technology and if you do nobody's  going to have a job